[Music]
what is the science behind grounding and
how can i explain it to my husband who
dislikes anything he perceives as hippie
or spiritual sounds like me
this is the number one question because
even i who have benefited so much from
earthing
i have trouble explaining it in a way
that doesn't seem absolutely insane but
thankfully we have clint over here who
wrote this book with the medical doctor
and martin zucker and and so there's a
lot of science in the book but what is
the science behind grounding how do i
explain it to a layperson clint
well
i've
spent 23 years
trying to do that
and i'm still very challenged
but the thing i've learned over the
years is the only way
you can really explain
what grounding i can explain it
technically it's very simple the earth
has a negative charge that's why we
ground everything electrical to the
earth in order to maintain electrical
stability the human body is the most
electrical thing in our environment and
it
and it used to be naturally grounded to
the earth before the 60s when we
invented
rubber soles shoes but everything in the
body needs
to i mean we need to be grounded and for
electrical stability and primarily our
immune system but it takes a little bit
to explain that and most people don't
want to learn the tech they don't want
to learn the science they just said if
this works um give me give me two i need
one for me and one for my mom
but basically what i have learned is
i started out grounding people one at a
time
23 years ago
and then sometimes 100 at a time
sometimes 300 500 800
the longevity conferences with david
wolf we would ground up to 1500 people
at a time but by grounding people and
letting them experience it for a half
hour or an hour or three days during a
seminar uh it's life-changing and people
get up and say why didn't somebody tell
me about this
and it's really a challenge so it's
really the best way to understand
grounding is to look at the earthing
movie because there is a body of
evidence
that speaks to most
women moms and caregivers and then go
outdoors take a chair put your take your
shoes off put your put the chair
outdoors on the grass put your feet on
the grass or just sit on the grass with
your hands and your feet and experience
grounding yeah if you have inflammation
and
pain in your but if you have pain in
your body you have inflammation you
can't have pain without inflammation so
what grounding does is it reduces the
inflammation in your body there's a
whole science behind it there's 20
peer-reviewed published studies on it
uh you have the earthing movie there's a
plethora of
material out there
but it's really as simple as going
outdoors and doing your own study
putting your bare feet on the earth
putting your hands on the earth and
notice the difference you'll go to the
beach for a few hours yeah and notice
how you feel after you
like after i go surfing like i mean i'm
tired but i always feel more relaxed
when i get out of the ocean for sure so
but but it's really it's it's all about
we used to be
naturally grounded all animals who live
in nature they are naturally grounded
they don't suffer cardiovascular disease
lupus ms autism and cancer and all of
these modern health disorders yet the
animals who live indoors with their
owners they all suffer the same
health disorders as their owners
meaning 50 of them die from cancer just
like their owners but cancer rarely
exists if at all in nature
so
is we've disconnected from this
energetic source that maintains the
electrical stability of the body and
primarily the immune system yeah so so
you could you know scientifically talk
about like the charge that the body
holds and how this basically creates a
perfect environment for inflammation to
to persist and how grounding can kind of
take out that uh that electric charge
but really what i hear you saying clint
is seeing is believing and that's how
most of us really are try it out for
ourselves actually see how it works you
got to do your own research yeah but
it's free yeah and it's enjoyable it's
fun yeah i totally and so when i first
heard about this i'm like okay let me
i'm i'm in so much pain at the time not
anymore thanks to clint and thanks to
earthing thanks to mother earth in
general he just helped connect me
reconnect me to the earth
and what i realized is oh
i'm 40 now
i've been disconnected even as i was
pictures of me as a baby learning to
walk with shoes on yeah
i have been so disconnected from the
earth and i didn't realize that i was an
electro
electrical being i don't know a whole
lot about biology i don't know a whole
lot about electricity i don't know a
whole lot about earth and electrons and
negative charge versus positive charge i
know a lot now because i read earthing
and what earthing did for me is it made
it real not only are there real life
stories in your book of real life people
who have healed
it convinced me enough without trying to
convince me it convinced me of seeing
these other people it's at least worth
trying yeah and i remember the first day
that i went earthing it was free i had
no product no service no subscription no
money paid i simply took my shoes off
put them in the dirt and
not instantly but within an hour
i started to feel some relief yeah and
then i started grounding every night
eventually i went to a clinton and got
some i paid for all of it this is not
this is not a sponsored sort of thing
right here um
we've got a grounding mat for my bed
we're standing on grounding mats here in
our studio right now that connect us
back to the earth so you don't have to
have any products earthing is 100 free i
was in the ocean this weekend and how
wonderful is that free earthing but what
i noticed after a couple weeks after six
weeks
my whole life
had changed appreciably and what i
noticed is that grounding didn't heal me
it's almost as though it was removing
the things that were creating the
dis-ease in my life did you enjoy this
stand-alone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free